hey I'm bangbang and I'm gonna answer
some tattoo questions on Twitter let's
get started do you reckon my tattoo
artist to be mad at me if I have spots
where I'm getting tattooed will it make
it difficult for her how do you get rid
of acne on your body please your tattoos
I hope won't be mad at you you can't
help blemishes but in some cases it can
restrict what we can do and it can
affect how it heals and if you get a
tattoo where you don't have blemishes or
acne and you develop it it can actually
push ink out this is what that looks
like there's a spot here that's missing
this is certainly from a pimple or
getting scratched there's another one
right here see a dermatologist see if
you can take care of it and then get a
tattoo
whenever there's some question like that
we're like see the doctor and see if we
can take care of it from little ink
stain sounds like we can be friends
there has to be a better way to practice
tattoos beside fruit and just people
it's pig skin isn't it Oh God that makes
me gag it will pig skin doesn't smell
good my apprentice used to have to go to
the butcher and pick up pig scraps and
skin and tattoo it and she has to do it
quick because we had to get it out of
storks it smelly there are now like
artificial body parts so silicones that
you can tattoo on and fake skin that's
really good for kind of getting your
hand used to the weight of a tattoo
machine drawing with something vibrating
keeping your deaths consistent so just
warming your hand up to using the tool
you can't learn how to drive a car in a
video game like you have to get behind a
car and drive so first off you should
tattoo yourself when you're learning so
you can feel what it is you're doing and
yeah I mean if you don't trust yourself
enough to tattoo yourself why should
other people trust you so I've tattooed
myself a dozen times I still tattoo
myself yeah I did my little 14 left
handed I did my little number too
it's not that good
not a cry for help what's the best way
to do a stick and poke tattoo I've tried
in the past and only gotten two dots
that stayed don't do that man you don't
know what you're doing don't do it I
don't know how to answer this question
it's like how do I go get in a car
accident like don't from Mia okay but
how to tattoo artists do shading like I
can hardly do it on paper how do you do
it on skin magic pure magic there's a
lot of variables that go into tattooing
the needle densities how they're laid
out depth and pressure speed of our
machine and then also how diluted the
ink is so we used several different
tones to make it happen and we kind of
all blend it together let me show you
how that's done when we're tattooing we
use several different types of needles
different groupings different sizes one
that's most specific to shading is
called a mag and it's very much like a
brush this one is 15 needles and they're
stacked on top of each other the
technique is really to move that across
the skin evenly consistently without
damaging so that's the task we use
individual grips each time that we
tattoo so the stuff is all disposable
and another interesting thing is they
they don't have to be these things can
be made out of stainless steel and
cleaned and reused in many states you
can even reuse the tattoo needle so it's
really important to ask we really
recommend people always use brand new
needles every time this is the fun part
what I'm doing right now is not
necessarily like solid line I'm trying
to kind of brush it in with
my liner make sure I keep that realism
because things that are realistic don't
have hard lines all around them so I
have to make sure I just put the
contrast just where it goes to make sure
it still looks realistic there's all
different kinds of like how sharp its
tapered there's different bluntness --es
and different sharpness --is of the
needles different groupings how close
they are together the different gauges
are health thick each needle is when
tattooing started there was no companies
making tattoo needles so you had to make
your own so the grouping is specific to
the artist so as I'm shading I can
dilute my inks with water and I can also
move my hand a bit faster to change that
tone I can use darker inks and get this
area completely to black if I need to I
can I use a sweeping motion so it has to
be in the skin the same depth and time
in the forward motion as the backward
motion the depth is really important
that's how you can kind of create one
tone of pigment over a really large
plane is move your hand the exact same
way for several hours in a row my tattoo
is starting to peel and a piece of
completely black skin just came off of
it in the shower help yeah it's normal
you'll be fine
it's not skin that came off it's dried
plasma or you know your scab your body
is regenerating and you have seven
layers of skin we're putting ink in
between the third and fourth layer if
it's done successfully you'll shed your
top layer it's totally normal
how do you fit a skull rainbow and a
black rose on one tattoo it's really
like the balance you need to find in any
design that'll make it timeless I feel
like almost any subject matter you can
piece together as long as you can make
sense of it you know when you're old and
gray you're still gonna have your skull
black rose and rainbow tattoo how do we
make it pleasing to the eye this is how
I would do that so first I'll pull the
clients body part into Photoshop and
then organically laying each image on to
see which one's you know gonna kind of
be the dominant image and which ones are
gonna be backgrounds I want to work with
the client to make sure they feel
comfortable in the design
and people are gonna just understand
what I tell them what I'm gonna do so I
want to give them a visual
representation of it almost every larger
tattoo I make I will work in Photoshop
with people not everything that I try I
like so this is very much the sketch
process so if we want to do any really
fine detailed stuff I will do all that
by hand really close if I want to add
any motion to that that's all something
I can add just with some of my smudge
tools and we can carry some of that
background to fit the body part and this
is all something that I wouldn't
necessarily map for myself before I
tattoo it but it's something that helps
clients get an idea of what I'm going
for on their skin so now we're really
close I can just put a filter on these
that will make it look like a finished
tattoo and then I'm gonna pull that rose
just in front of that rainbow and I
think that's gonna do it brighten that
rose up a little bit and there you go
there's a rose and a rainbow and a skull
it doesn't always work but I think it's
pretty cool
I thought it would be worse yeah I want
to make that tattoo so hollow tattoo
myth or fact coloring Kurt's more than
black ink certain techniques hurt more
than other techniques sometimes color
needs more effort from the artist skin
needs to get beat up a little bit more
for that color to put as much pigment in
your skin as possible if a pigment is
thicker it's going to take longer and be
a little tougher to get into your skin
so different colors have different
consistencies through different
companies of brands that make them white
hurts because we're drilling it we're
trying to get as much in there as
possible tattoos of the insanely itchy
stage can't decide if best technique is
blowing tapping itching around it or
distraction through alcohol sounds like
we can be friends yeah slap it that's
the best one if you itch it you can
force off scabs or effective if there's
no scabs on your tattoo go for it it's
away enjoy if you have little scabs or
it's still healing very fresh within the
first you know ten days or two weeks
don't itch your tattoo your nails are
also gross so you know if it's killing
you like smack it ice helps you can put
ice on it friends with tattoos
question what's the best way to wrap a
fresh tattoo my Santa Durham fell off
and it hasn't been a full 24 hours
I got a significant amount of color done
and I'm worried about leaking plasma and
my tattoo scabbing attaching itself to
clothing it is on your tattoo artist to
make sure they educate you when your
tattoo is done and that they're there
for you when you do have questions when
I do a highly rendered full-color tattoo
that's more trauma to skin than any
other style because it's very densely
tattooed trying to make color very solid
your tattoo will ooze more it'll scab
more wash your tattoo all that plasma
and gross that's gonna come to the
surface and leak should be washed off
gently with warm water and soap and let
it get air I wrap tattoos for two to 24
hours your body really does the healing
the things you put on top of your body
are not going to heal you your body's
gonna heal you there's things that can
promote healing and there's things that
can kind of restrict healing
let me demonstrate that I'm going to do
one final wash of his tattoo I'm gonna
apply some ointment and I'm gonna put
plastic on top we're gonna make sure the
tattoo is really clean before we wrap it
after we wrap it we'll go through the
next steps in a couple hours
this will all be absorbed by the skin
and and when he takes this bandage off
he'll wash this all off appointment is
not helping your tattoo heal in any way
it's just keeping your skin protected or
moisturized so your body can do the work
so I'm gonna use your chest first I
personally don't use Sanna derm
it's essentially a little bit thicker
plastic wrap with glue all over it it's
applied to the skin it sticks on almost
like a secondary skin so you can you can
touch it similarly to this but it won't
come off you don't need to tape it on
the healing properties are gone within
24 hours so you really need to remove
that wash the area and you can reapply
senador it's sticking to a tattoo is not
the best for what I do so I use plain
plastic wrap and I think it works pretty
well for example if the shirt he wore
into this store if there's any sweat in
that shirt there's bacteria in that we
don't want that in contact with his
tattoo if when he gets home and he takes
that shirt off that brand new tattoo
gets scratched by his his
nails his watch even the shower curtain
is he's entering we want to keep it
really clean he's gonna get in the
shower he's gonna remove this he's gonna
wash his hands wash his tattoo had it
dry with a freshly cleaned towel and let
it get hair let it breathe your tax his
breathing your touch is healing what's
your favorite tattoo on Justin Bieber I
got to tattoo his torso and fill in a
bunch of gaps and that was really fun he
had a son of God written on his stomach
and it looked like it said sent food so
I text him right away I was like man we
need to work on this he had so many
tattoos on his stomach of so many
different varying subjects it was like
how am I gonna ties together make this
one story so big cross send food an
eagle
a bear and a lion and I was like alright
well how would we tie all this together
so we used some reference of old
Renaissance paintings of religious works
try to tie a story of religion and
spirit treating these animals like they
are his spirit animals or his protectors
and then treating the rest of his torso
in the subject of religion that was
challenging I wish that I could have a
blank slate and tattoo him without all
the obstacles but like I kind of like
the challenge so I think that's my
favorite he's got a bunch of crummy ones
and he knows it so do i when you have a
bunch of tattoos and you're kind of a
little loose about it you're gonna get
some crummy ones how do you tattoo
artists learn and practice their craft
it's a really good question
there is no standard format or education
for tattooing the traditional method to
getting into tattooing is to find a
great tattoo artist and have them teach
you so an apprenticeship program it's
tough work you have to draw and draw and
draw and so you don't want to draw
anymore your art has to improve you have
to show that person who's teaching you
you are worth their effort and that you
deserve to be a tattoo artist that you
love tattooing so much that you'll work
your fingers to the bone to become a
great one hopefully someday there will
be a format to tattoo education do
tattoo artists ever just refuse to do a
horrible tattoo idea because they know
the client will regret it later
I will refuse a tattoo if I don't think
it's gonna be a great tattoo so if I
can't see it in my head or if the idea
there for me it's certainly not going to
be good once it's on you if I'm not
confident in it I am NOT gonna make it
for you
people don't design tattoos for a living
I do if you're coming to me I'm not just
making your sandwich the way you like it
I'm gonna make the tattoo the way I know
it'll be a great and unique and fit you
and your person and if I'm not feeling
it I'm not making it my favorite client
in the world is Rihanna several times
she's come in with ideas I didn't think
we're gonna work Google real hard you'll
find her walking around the streets in
New York City in 2007 with a stencil of
a guitar broken in half with a pair of
underwear hanging off it on her arm it's
because we went really far in this
design and I wasn't feeling it and I
didn't like it and I told her like go
home and live with it and we'll talk
about it tomorrow and see if you're
still feeling we'll talk about in the
week we didn't make it and I'm glad that
I kind of pumped the brakes on that Cara
Delevingne has a really iconic lion
tattoo on her finger when I met her she
wanted the word lion el i/o and straight
down her finger your skin on your finger
is really inconsistent it's very hard to
tattoo fingers in general let alone
moving through different types of skin
in a very small area
I want tattoos to be visually appealing
I think it would be hard to read the
word lion down her finger number one I
think it would have been inconsistent if
we'd done that text and so I made the
recommendation that we treat it like a
piece of jewelry and do very similar
what I have on my fingers and make it
more of a ring more of a decoration
let's make an actual Lions face and
credit to her she was like yeah I'm down
and it's cool I've seen that tattoo all
over the world and big billboards and
she's really like kind of transcended
you know modeling and bridged that gap
between fashion and tattooing as much as
Rihanna has you know what happens if you
get a big-ass tattoo on your thigh or
something and you lose a bunch of weight
and your thigh is super tiny now tattoos
gonna be super tiny now tattoos gonna
move with your skin so if your skin
changes shape size your your tattoo will
do the same oftentimes the reverse thing
happens if someone gains weight your
tattoo can grow or it can migrate based
on where the skin stretches from the
tattoo will move if your tattoo is on a
pole
where your body is stretching from the
tattoo will stretch this happens on
pregnant women on their stomachs and
sometimes you can come back to normal
and be just fine and sometimes it won't
stretch marks can move through a tattoo
and really distort the image two artists
at bang-bang know how to tattoo colors
on brown skin because I'm looking
through IG and all I see is white people
I get this a lot and I would say look
harder we live in New York City the
minority of our clientele are white
people are from all over the world and
tones of skin are really hard to see
when you are shooting just an arm we
often desaturate a photograph to take
away the redness of a fresh tattoo and
that changes the tone of the photo when
you're seeing an arm from here to here
you can't tell that person's ethnicity
don't assume that every client you're
looking at is has white skin it's really
not not the case we took a ton of
athletes celebrities forget ethnicity
for a moment think about your tone of
your skin because that's how we see it
so if you're gonna draw a picture and
you take a white piece of paper and you
want to draw on it it's gonna show a lot
and if you take a darker piece of paper
and you use a yellow marker on it it's
not gonna come through but if you use a
darker tone like a red blue in some
cases greens they come through a lot
more so based on the hue of someone's
tone we kind of pick which colors are
gonna work best this question always
upsets me because I feel like people
feel left out and you're not at all I
think you just can't tell what ethnicity
people are in our photos so yeah don't
feel that way
sorry it comes off that way what's the
worst tattoo you have ever seen so many
celebrities are running through my head
that have bad tattoos like I don't want
to be that guy I think my least favorite
tattoo that I've seen stuff really big
tattoo of huge roses larger than life on
someone's whole butt
that's not super attractive from Laura
how do you tattoo artists draw perfect
circles with extreme difficulty
tattooing very stressful there's nothing
that shows imperfection like a circle or
two circles right next to each other
it's like really easy for the eye to see
mistakes we do it really carefully
really slowly
we kind of dive in and hope at the end
we're like who made it tattoos do you
have any if you do what's your favorite
one I've bunch but mine would have to be
some of the faces I have I've always
really loved my hand tattoos they're all
really special milestones for me I got
the Statue of Liberty tattooed on my
hand when I had tattooed in New York for
ten years and I got the Empire State
Building tattooed on my hand when I
thought that I had opened the best
tattoo shop in New York and I have
Mickey Mouse because I like Mickey I
hope I've answered your questions I hope
you've learned something and I hope you
go get great tattoos